ich habe mir jetzt erkennt man eine
punkte schon aber ich kann noch nicht
mal die note ich habe jetzt ist die
tabelle gezeigt ist dabei was leute habe
ich den hauptschulabschluss kessel matte
gestanden oder nicht herzlich ein zu
einer video leute auf das ich mich so
krass feuer wenn ich euch jetzt sagen
worum es in diesem video geht werden
einige von euch sich massiv an den kopf
fassen denn ich werde heute freiwillig
eine abschlussprüfung im fach mathematik
schreiben ich bin deswegen so aufgeregt
leute weil ich hier eine original
hauptschulabschlussprüfung im fach mathe
aus dem jahr 2007 habe habe ich das
thema scharf gestellt jetzt auch gerade
abschlussprüfungen von der hansestadt
hamburg und ja keine also ich finde
einfach diese herausforderung sogar hält
deswegen setze ich mich jetzt hier hin
und schreibe freiwillig 135 minuten lang
an diesem test mit komplett in original
regeln die ich euch jetzt erklären also
schauen wir drauf arbeitszeit insgesamt
130 minuten den ersten prüfungsteil dass
es aufgabe eines muss man ohne
taschenrechner mache mache ich auch
komplett ohne gibt es bis zu 45 minuten
danach lege ich den ersten aufgaben teil
weg und muss dann aus vier aufgaben drei
auswählen die im zweiten prüfungsteil
mache den zweiten davon mit
taschenrechner machen und dann am ende
werde ich das meinem bruder zur
korrektur geben leute und ich würde
sagen ich baue jetzt mal alles hier auf
und machen wir das einfach
okay leute wir haben jetzt 14 45 wir
haben 135 minuten also zwei stunden 15
minuten bearbeitungszeit das heißt bis
17 uhr das jetzt eine nicht vertretbare
uhr ist hier oben der ptb punkt.de die
uhr ist live mit livestream da kann man
nix dann verändern anders als zum
beispiel war der iphone nur die man
natürlich die sie verstehen kann ich
weiß nicht welche deutsche youtuber
rinnen das jetzt hören muss
möglicherweise macht sie er von der
schelte videos weil es aber nicht genau
hier ist mein nicht programmierbare
versprechen dann habe ich so genau auf
dem abitur verwendet und auch mit meinem
studium smart ist kultur war auch damit
ihr seht ok chef vom dienst auf
ausgefüllt nach in der tasche hat jetzt
auch weg für aufgaben allein den dadurch
erst ab 15.30 für aufgaben teil 2
benutzen präsentiert es noch mal fünf
minuten von der prüfungs zeit vergeudet
wirft gar nicht bei mir gab es heute
respekt löst der name ist es kay klasse
9a ein bisschen wiederholt für markier
so sind die aufgabe aus oder taschen
sind jetzt hier 29 x pire rechnen 45 x
10 x 100 rechnen weiter mit john trägt
neben htc als lösung da ein und dann ja
von den aufgaben kann jetzt mal so
machen
29 x 420 x 84 94 36 116 also 10,5 x 10 x
145 x 105 100 also a
[Musik]
bestimme das gefäß das zu diesem
fotografen passt früher habe ich von
zeit und sie hat schon ein paar machte
brief mit meinem leben geschrieben heute
aber ich muss noch nie füllgraf zum
gefäß zu ordnen
ich komme jeden fall gut durch ich habe
aufgaben teil eins schon komplett
bearbeitet hier
es ist jetzt 15 uhr 3 ich weiß nicht
genau wann ich angefangen habe ich
könnte mal die zeit eigentlich gebraucht
habe 45 minuten hätte ich gehabt ich
weiß aber weiter mit den restlichen drei
aufgaben vielleicht komme ich ja
insgesamt schneller durch wertigkeit für
mich da jetzt hinzunehmen aufgabe 1
kommt weg taschenrechner und die auf co2
auch kaum zweifel ob das schon mal ganz
anders aus aber okay aufgabe 1 habe ich
jetzt durchgerechnet lösungen wie das
wort geschrieben ich jetzt keine extra
zettel irgendwie brauchen wollte oder so
15 uhr
12 an sich habe ich für aufgabe 1
rechner rechten ja eine halbe stunde zur
verfügung und ich habe jetzt wenn ich
jetzt hier mal eigentlich für dich
gebraucht haben wir sie auch selbst im
video ja okay jetzt wird sogar schon
drei vier leute der messe hier eine
aufgabe zum schwimmbecken und hartmann
dem schwimmbecken man kann das volumen
von den film becken aus rechnet man so
haben wir zum beispiel verschiedene
punkten die unterschiedlich viele liter
pro minute pumpen also man ausrechnen
wie hoch der wasserstand in diesem
schwimmbecken nach zehn stunden dass das
auf jeden fall schon ein ganz
schwieriger als die anfangs aufgaben
aber es ist noch ganz gute nachbar finde
ich dass man extra zugenommen und worte
passen glaube ich
[Musik]
okay leute ich bin fertig und ich muss
sagen ich bin tatsächlich deutlich
schneller kommen als ich dachte ich
zeige euch habe um eine arbeitsplatte
hinten auf dem zuschaueraufkommen bad
einzigen dass wir schon fertig gehabt
und jetzt habe ich die aufgabe zwei
fertiggemacht aufgabe 3 war das mit dem
schwimmbad die habe ich auch fertig
gemacht und hierbei aufgabe hier ging es
um handyverträge welcher günstiger ist
und soll dann muss man ein bisschen mit
funktionen arbeiten habe ich auch fertig
gemacht hiermit lösung auf dem
nebenplatz und die zeit seit 15 39 also
habe ich das ganze jetzt in 50 minuten
gemacht das ist an sich erst mal dort
schneller als die zeit vorgegeben das
ist ja zwei stunden 15 vorgegeben ich
habs jetzt in einer guten
dreiviertelstunde gemacht allerdings ist
noch nicht gesagt dass alles richtig ist
ich hier sehe ich auch keinen sinn mehr
da mal drüber zu gehen
ich gebe jetzt einfach mal so bei max ab
dann werden wir jetzt gleich in der
korrektur sehen ob ich überall frick war
oder ob ich tatsächlich bestanden habe
also das ist max büro und als wäre es
vorher abgesprochen dass er korrigiert
sitzt er bereits da dies ist mein lehrer
warum ist mein lehrer mein kleiner
bruder bei thun horn das ist meine
hauptschulabschluss test in mathe wir in
50 minuten geschrieben was ist denn der
hat leider nicht gereicht
das korrigiere ich das jetzt auch noch
zeit und dann müssen wir gleich meine
noten verteilen ist hier sehen wir den
unbarmherzigen lehrer bei der korrektur
die lösungs vorlage 2000 aus dem
internet hervor
ich wollte einen punkt abgegeben weil
ich den antwort satz nicht komplett
richtig aus formuliert habe
ja also man muss wirklich sagen leute
ich hab da fehlt ja die schule routine
ja ja ja wenn du wüsstest das gängig ist
weil hier steht ja nirgendwo schreiben
sie den anderen ja also deswegen muss
man bei derzeit bei mir wissen was
aufschlagen leute aber ich hab halt
oftmals hat nur die rechnungen
geschrieben weil der so wenig recht
haben dann kann ich auch im deutschen
sachsen entsprechen also an sich muss
man sagen okay man muss für meine
bearbeitungszeit auf jeden fall ein
bisschen zeit aufschlagen 20
viertelstunde halbe stunde oder so hat
er für die letzte halt ausformulieren so
das hätte ich natürlich in der echten
schulprüfungen gemacht aber der putter
pro lebens ist habe niemals einen
kleinen bruder ist lehrer allgemeinen
ebenfalls schwierig aber wer würde ich
so hopp
so leute ich habe jetzt die ganze zeit
nicht im lehrerzimmer und ich glaube wir
haben eine gesamtpunktzahl hat doch
schon eine note ich weiß nicht wie man
die bestimmen das ist auch eine tour
durch die hauptstadt
ich habe mir jetzt erkennt meine punkte
schon aber er kann noch nicht mal die
note ich bin jetzt ist die tabelle
gezeigt ist dabei heute habe ich den
hauptschulabschluss testen matte
gestanden oder nicht jetzt wird sich
zeigen
selbst sehr schlecht 6,1 sehr schlecht
die leistung hier 90 von 100 mit 95
hättest du dir eins plus gehabt aber per
kran kann hier nur die 1
aber es ist keine fünfzehn speedrun 50
hauptschulabschluss herzkrankheit dass
das lernst du hast du dein vater herzog
wallisellen ja nichts damit ihren
bachelor diaby aber auch wieder
abgegeben
sehr gut also die wirklich kräftig war
geisteskrank alt auf dieses video
findest immer noch einfach dieses
selbstbild zu machen oder es ist ja doch
ganz gut gelaufen das ganze ist jetzt
natürlich auch in keinem fall irgendein
front an leute die vielleicht in ihrem
eigenen haus test da schlechter
abgeschlossen haben ist natürlich eine
andere situation an der schule ist
stress hat so dass seine ganze sache
kann man nicht eins zu eins zu
vergleichen ich hatte ja auch nicht 100
prozent die exakte prüfungsbedingungen
wie ihr zuhause aber ja schreiben auch
nur die kommentare was hier verhalten
ganz wichtig schreibt mir rein ob ich
das ganze mal vielleicht mit dem
realschulabschluss auch probieren sollte
meist dadurch eine chance max oder mit
dem auto oder mit dem master englisch ab
ich mache ich ohne lernen das ist ja ich
hab die computer chip vorgestellt um
einen kanal
ich bin raus was gut mit ihm